hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal waren
und bekommt zu einem neuen video von mir
ich bin gerade in köln auf dem weg zum
dreh für die reihe deine chemie
das ist kooperation entstanden mit der
chemischen industrie und ich würde sagen
let's go und wenn ich schon mal in köln
bin möchte ich unbedingt hier mal einen
döner ausprobieren als berlinerin bin
ich ja quasi döner experten also gut
currywurst ist jetzt auch aber dünner
auch und der zugewinn es mal richtig
schöne genommen und sicherheit geht vor
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich aber auch wirklich los
hat jemand sein smartphone gegen ist das
bin ich
oh mein gott da habe ich ja echt glück
gehabt
aber mein ultraleichter stylischer helm
schützt mich nicht nur er verfügt auch
über eine freisprecheinrichtung zum
telefonieren lautsprecher bremsleuchten
und flinker nach einem sturz sendet er
sogar einen notruf ab wahnsinn was da
alles rein passt auch dank der chemie
hightech materialien von der chemie
sorgen dafür dass elektronische bauteile
wie zum beispiel mikrochips leuchten
oder speicher und funkmodule immer
kleiner werden und in den
unterschiedlichen geräten platz finden
wo ist eigentlich das smartphone
kranker scheiß
ich muss das doch irgendwie finden
hallo
dieser fahrradrahmen besteht aus karbon
der hightech werkstoff von der chemie
ist stabiler als stahl aber bis zu 80
prozent leichter carbon ist auch
besonders steif so dass die energie die
man in die pedale steckt optimal
weitergeleitet wird
[Musik]
ist auch nur ein mensch wie ihr nun
hängt alles ist gut
oh ja doch nicht gut kommt nimmt es und
zieht wieder ach ja könnte ich tauschen
wir tauschen boehner gegen smartphone
ganz einfach
[Musik]
ja es hat kein berliner döner
hier habe ich bin der herrscher und an
und aus in welcher farbe die leds
leuchten bestimmt die chemie durch die
darin enthaltenen halbleitermaterialien
stromsparend und langlebig sind leds in
jedem fall das macht sie zur idealen
lösung für sämtliche beleuchtungs
aufgaben nicht überzeugt ich auch nicht
so ne
das kennt ihr aber sicher nicht die
vulkanisation macht auto greift für den
reifen durch dieses chemische technische
verfahren wird der kautschuk dauer
elastisch und kehrt immer wieder in
seine ursprüngliche form zurück
auch ist der reifen dadurch
widerstandsfähiger gegen witterung und
alterung
smartphone damit ich nach hause kam und
ihr das hier tauschen
aber diesmal wirklich tauschen
[Musik]
also
und jetzt
[Musik]
wir haben spaß muss wirklich nach hause
bitte bitte funktioniert das ja ich bin
ich habe mich noch hunger wie später
geht's nach leute das war jetzt ein mega
krass ich hab hunger zum dreh habe ich
nicht geschafft ich habe mein fahrrad
verloren aber ich meine com in der
steinzeit also immer positiv bleiben
[Musik]
vielen dank noch mal an die chemische
industrie für diese kooperation im
rahmen der reihe
deine chemie mehr dazu findet ihr
natürlich in der infobox auf zeitreise
gehen nämlich auch david die real life
geis falco und fresh torge von dem auch
die nächste episode stammt viel spaß
wünscht ihr euch damit und bis bald eure
mal wanne